yo it's power 98.3 man ready set radio
in the building this dude is on the
cover of the new double xl freshman
class he's popping right now just signed
a def jam maryland zone we got the homie
logic in the building what's up man
what's going on i'm chillin man how was
uh this tour you are on your tour right
now i think is this the first time
you've been to az yes okay first time so
it's good man it's going really great
we're selling out these shows it's crazy
it's it's an honor to be able to come to
cities i've never been at before and
just sell out and have fans here man
it's crazy you missed barely missed the
like 115 120 weather you got here like
perfect timing okay good yeah because
it's already hot outside man oh no it's
not hot yet
it gets really bad out here i can
imagine um i want to talk to you man uh
being on this double xl cover is always
a gift or a curse to some people yeah
for most people you know it's it's
really kind of what catapults them to
that next level there's been a legendary
you know group of mc's have been on the
cover before yeah um
how in this short amount of time since
you've been on the cover how has it kind
of changed your life um it's changed my
life in definitely a huge way and i tell
people all the time like i was even
talking to vanessa statten you know who
runs double xl and she was like how is
it different for you she's like because
i don't see it she's like you know just
because of it she's like how is it
different i was like in many ways it
changed my life because
um i already had fans you know and it
was crazy that like if i had toured to
other countries in the world and you
know i'd i'd be like
rapping and these kids and are in the
front row wrapping every single lyric
and then we'll do like a meet and greet
afterwards and we can't even have a
conversation because they don't speak
english and it's crazy to have already
had that before it's like that wu-tang
effect dude completely yeah and i feel
like uh hip-hop is like this very small
circle of taste makers and and other you
know just just kind of cosigns and all
that and that's something that i wasn't
in and you have a lot of artists that
start there and then from that go out
and do their best to get fans like real
fans the difference between somebody who
just listens and kind of oh i know that
record oh this is cool
exactly
and i was blessed enough to kind of do
it backwards and build this huge fan
base and then be accepted by hip hop
from this double xl cover from signing
to one of the most iconic hip-hop uh
labels def jam from being able to work
with and have somebody executive produce
my album like no id so
i think you know it's those things that
allowed people to go oh damn like i feel
like it's kind of cool cause like you
said you really weren't i think guys
like yourself and dizzy
like weren't really
popping in that circle that you're
completely about yeah man you know what
i mean and dizzy's the homie and i think
it's just a lot of it is just perception
and a lot of it is
is uh
just kind of openness like are you are
you willing to accept accept someone for
what they represent and when when people
are kind of different i think it's hard
for them too much the same way last year
i felt like nobody was checking for
macklemore exactly at all very true you
know and and now it is what it is man
running ish right now yeah he is um okay
so how did you link up with no id who to
me is always
very very under underrated when people
talk about the best producers ever dude
yes without a doubt that's in my top
five personal favorite yeah he's
incredible man um
long story short you know there was a
time when when pretty much every major
and also very like high independent
labels through majors like imprints
wanted to sign me you know from
universal to idj to def jam to warner to
everybody you know we were we were
talking to but
um no id was the only person who got it
you know and noah preston who is my nr
over at def jam and a good friend of
mine he's the guy who you know kind of
scouted and found me and then brought
that to no idea's attention and i think
the reason he was is because like you
know how i told you it's hard for people
to accept something that's different
yeah and me like my style is is almost
like a melting pot of
various styles you know what i'm saying
from being able to do that kind of
melodic uh drake thing you know having
fun with that commercial but then able
to do like that raw j coalish nas big l
sound and i i feel like
with no idea i mean he kept it real with
me he was like you can recreate raw
records like they're from the 90s and
you can also create commercial records
without jeopardizing or sacrificing
yourself your integrity or who you are
as an artist
yeah yeah well i take pride in it
because i'm just i love all music and i
love to create music and at the end of
the day that's what it is it's it's just
music you have a preference you either
like it or you don't like it and me i
just make music and and represent for me
and my team and just have fun man but
yeah that's why i went with him because
he got it that's what's up do you find
it harder being from somewhere that's
not necessarily on the national hip hop
map being from maryland because like
we're in phoenix and i feel like it's
the same kind of struggle like phoenix
is a big city you know what i mean but
it's there's no identity in the hip-hop
world
honestly i think it's the same no matter
where you are because at the end of the
day it's hustle and even though like you
know the dmv has incredible immense
talent you know and there's people out
there from philadelphia to fat trail i
mean there's just it goes on and on um
but it's just like anywhere else it
wouldn't matter if it was new york city
filled with millions
that definitely without a doubt you know
what i'm saying i think it just comes
down to the individual hustle i think it
comes down to the talent of the person
and to the the business mind and
marketing of the uh you know management
and the label that you're working with
that's what it comes down to that's
what's up so welcome to forever it's the
tape that is out right now the newest
tape
and uh on the tape
you you had uh pops from uh
friday on there yeah uh how did you get
i how did that happen man i thought that
was such a funny ski yeah man that was
that was funny and obviously you know
that was like a joke playing on my race
being black and white and having fun
with that and
with with the whole thing like basically
so noah preston my anr that's kind of
like like his second dad like they he
always yeah he was always around him
because he he knew his sons and they
were all really good friends growing up
and things like that and it was more of
like a personal thing like hey how would
you feel about doing this fun skit for
my artist and he was like yeah let me
meet him obviously you want to meet
somebody before you work with him and
you know he was a really great guy and
we just clicked and um i also
know his son who who's also a producer
really cool young guy and um and it's
just it just worked out were you guys in
the studio together
uh me and john like when we did it yeah
it was really funny because i was in the
booth with him because my uh my
videographer gravity had you know he
wanted to record it all yeah so we did
it i mean not to like ruin the magic but
you know he did his take and then i did
my take and i wrote that whole script
myself and he basically kind of followed
that but like did his own fun thing yeah
of course i mean that's why i probed on
it yeah yeah and it just it just worked
out and it's i think it came out really
good do you feel like i because of
course i think when anybody first sees
you if they're not into your music they
think you're a white boy you know what i
mean yeah um
how important is it to you i i know you
know listening to welcome to forever
clearly you know you you have records
and yeah lyrics that you know that let
everybody know what's up but like
do you does it matter that people just
think you're white because like you
anybody who looks at the double excel
freshman cover but there's a white guy
on the couch of course yeah yeah yeah
and it's funny because i think that that
was a
a lot like the biggest question like
who's logic right now i think it really
was if they know now you know like
without without a question and it's
really it's really awesome but me it's
just like i'm proud to be what i am on
black and white you know what i'm saying
like listen to cole's music listen to
drake's music listen to childish
gambino's music they talk about being
black and white right they do talk about
being perceived as black men but they
know that they are black and white
they're almost like on their own exactly
and it's really funny and i believe that
there's never really been an artist like
that you know a black and white artist
that looks 100 white and um
i don't know i love it you know and i
say this all the time kind of like uh
like dominicans like you know a lot of
dominicans they look more black yeah you
know what i'm saying but whenever i've
ran i have a lot of dominican friends
you know what i'm saying and i'll meet
him like oh you black and they'll be
like i'm dominican you know and they let
it be known and of course they're proud
of their ancestry and where they come
from but that's what they are
just like i'm black and white you know
i'm mixed so i saw the interview you did
with my girl ricky and we're talking
about trying to get into the acting
world once yes yeah one day one day uh
and you had mentioned something about uh
her saying something about my thing with
porn oh yeah are you a porno dude i i uh
are you a connoisseur i mean i'm a guy
i'm a dude you know what it is top three
porn stars man um
this is so funny trying to get me in
trouble man me and miley okay
aka she used to be calling mia moretti
back in the day i know that is true
that's how we know see that's how you
know that you're like a real fan because
you're you're hip you know did you ever
see the the kanye
tweet picture that yeah like and
everybody thought it was ken but it was
really a mia yeah that was like super
random um i don't know i'll tell you
that that's how you know i'm not that
into porn because i can't name all these
channels a good one yeah mia fam she
retired though there you go she did yeah
come back baby
i know too much i'm gonna i'm gonna
shout out yes
that's what's up so uh the dev jam uh
situation man it's a good look for you
uh you got the don't worry we've got
time man we're good you're touring and
i'm curious
are you how far along are you with the
uh debut album um you know it's funny
cause
like right now literally just a couple
minutes ago when i was in the tour bus
before we just met up like i was working
on the album you know saying like i got
beats i got lyrics i have ideas and i
also think it's really funny just to
bring this up i know it's kind of random
but
sometimes there's like you know quote
unquote fans out there who i guess
they're more hipster like oh i like your
old stuff better
and the funny thing is is like
for anybody to say that it's kind of bs
just because
like for example welcome to forever
welcome to forever is by far my best
work and i'm not just saying that in a
biased manner but because one the
production is bigger the lyrics are more
in depth i've gone through things and
i've also explained things more than i
ever have before like for example with
the whole being black and white i've
touched upon it very very little in my
previous records i mean talking about
growing up around narcotics and police
officers and and you know what i'm
saying like domestic violence in my home
these are all things that i never really
talked about and
so many of those records were written
before even the project before this
undeniable came out last year so it's
like little do people know and records
on my album i've been right i'm writing
right now i've been right people know
it's like years like my old stuff but
this is this is it you know and it's
like so many records that are going to
be on my album have already been thought
up in my head years before or even
written years before there's songs that
i've been working on for four five six
years that aren't even finished written
being written yet so i mean i'm excited
i don't know when it's just yet when
it's coming but i do know that i'm i'm
definitely in the process i'm going to
be way more in it once i'm off tour
because after this tour i got to go to
europe i'm doing wireless fest with jay
and justin timberlake and yeah and then
i got a couple other festivals and then
my own little quick mini tour i'm going
to paris and london and things like that
so once i come back from that and get
time to just really jump back in the
studio um we'll see where i am by then
but it's all positive when you write do
you do
i mean a lot of rappers these days they
don't write stuff down some do i mean
are you the kind of guy keep an old
school depend on the pad yeah well i
mean honestly now like i used to write i
have um pounds and pounds and pounds of
notebooks that are just full that you
know over the last nine years that i
just you know completely filled up so
now but it's a lot easier for me to just
write on my phone because it's so
accessible i'm always on my phone doing
business calls meetings emails things
like that and then my notes are right
there obviously everything is backed up
in gmail you know what i'm saying
yes but that it's just quick it's easy
simple to the points write my palm any
ideas that i have i just write them down
right then and there and yeah that's
what's up i know nas uh you met nas and
he had quoted some of your lyrics yeah
which we talked about when you called in
a couple weeks ago yeah um
what i don't know id and naz have a good
relationship i mean uh are you gonna be
able to get it get knives on the album
are you trying to work with now i mean i
would love to work with nas of course
who wouldn't you know they're saying
what are some features that there are
some realistic features that you feel
like you want to realistically you know
i mean everyone's going to be like jay-z
yeah yeah yeah of course yeah i know i
need that three stacks man but um
nas is somebody that i would i would
love to be able to work with and you
know from meeting him previously and and
knowing that he's a good dude and he
knows who i am and that we 100 respect
each other and i mean he's like a god of
hip-hop you know but but knowing that
you know i was in his ear and and that
we have a uh you know i've had a cool
relationship of just meeting one another
i feel like that is something that's
reasonable and that could happen for
sure especially just because of that
relationship with no id but even more
than that not just that co-sign
personally haven't you know met him
meeting him before i believe that's you
know reasonable uh somebody like j cole
i've met is a really good guy uh
kendrick who i've yet to meet but i
would love to be able to work with him
uh the homie kid cudi who recently
reached out to me so him
um yeah but i mean even more than that
dude anthony kiedis from the red hot
chili peppers the lead singer that'd be
awesome i'd love to work with jack black
uh yeah dude war paint which is a band
from la it's all girl band they're
incredible i'd love to work with them um
and just take it out of the box of just
hip hop john legend also is somebody
that i'd love to work with and me like
i'm never i've never been a huge fan of
like features you know like a million
features a million features i believe
that
yeah and artists should hold their own
especially a new artist yes
totally so with oh and also big sean the
homie really cool guy
i would definitely like to work with him
yeah but i feel that as far as
um working with
just hip hop i don't want to do that i
want to go outside of the spectrum and
that if i do have features it's not
going to be anybody that has to like
hold my weight rather someone who's
going to make the track better as a
whole